[Applaudissements]
regardez nos anciens il est très beau il
est encore plus beau que l'an dernier
erika je sais que vous craquez pour
bertrand série ça y est 3 qu'est ce qui
va se dire non mais j'ai dit moi je dis
j'ai dit j'ai dit bertrand
voilà j'ai dit quelque chose sur berck
est ce que tu as dit qu'est ce que tu
éduques atteindrait phrase c'est aussi
parce que cyril vadi met 200 ans tu vas
te retrouves à ton petit bertrand oui je
dis oui c'est vrai que bertrand
m'interpelle fameux touche c'est bien
d'avoir recruté des [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
tiens pas comment déjà votre mec bachar
il s'appelait bachar est simple et voilà
merci alors je vous dis
80% des personnes qui intègrent l'équipe
divorce ou changent de deux partenaires
voilà donc le regrette
voilà vous êtes prête noms mais je dire
il le sait pas d'accord moi je la sens
bien cette saison
[Applaudissements]
j'étais là sachez que cette année je
vais chopper